hi I'm RIA I'm a tasty producer today I
will be showing you how to make my
favorite recipes I've Lawrence since
coming to America some of the best fried
chicken I've ever had in the u.s. words
from howling rates in downtown LA and
Prince's hot chicken in Nashville
Tennessee
I wanted to recreate it so I don't need
to wait in line for two hours I've also
worked for a restaurant where they make
really good fried chicken so I combined
those techniques I recommend using
chicken thigh with the skin on for this
recipe
personally I like chicken thighs more
than the chicken breasts because it has
more flavor and it's more tender
another important component is
marinating the chicken in buttermilk
this technique it's definitely something
I learned after moving to the US because
buttermilk is not available in Japan
buttermilk is not available in your
country you can substitute it with milk
and lemon juice
Nashville Fried Chicken is spicier than
the one I made before and also uses the
flour instead of potato starch which
keeps more tender and crunchy exterior
the secret of this recipe eats after you
have Friday coded of its oil-based
seasoning sauce so the fried chicken
stays crispy this is a recipe I've never
heard of before coming to the u.s.
because we don't have anything with a
similar flavor palate in Japan I've come
to enjoy this dish as much as my chicken
wing recipe
but in a different way there is a
popular Japanese dish called a cream
color get it it's a croaker with a
creamy filling
just like chicken pot pie filling so I
mashed up those two dishes and made this
video there is a type of cuisine called
yosaku
which is a cuisine influenced by western
style cooking but adapted and evolved in
Japan Muricy hamburger with cheese
salisbury steak and croquettes are
considered your shop food Yoshio greets
my childhood favorite and i'm really
happy to see your shop it's getting more
attention recently it's actually quite
difficult to shape the cream filling but
if you divide the filling and freezer it
easier to shape one thing I've tried to
do with my cooking it's not only make
traditional Japanese dishes but try and
combine them with elements of other
cultures from around the world the first
time I had a chicken pot pie was
Kentucky Fried Chicken in Japan and I
really enjoyed it oftentimes family will
eat there for Christmas
it's an American comfort food I've
really come to enjoy and I thought this
would be an interesting way to combine
the flavors with something I was
familiar with already to give my own
unique take on that pie it's one of my
favorite American bizarre to eat and to
make arranging apple slices rod shape
needs some patience but it's totally was
die for this pie will impress whoever
you are eating with I combine sugar and
apple so apples become more pliable when
you combine sliced apples and sugar
sugar draws moisture out of the apples
and creates syrup don't discard it
because we are going to make caramel
sauce with this syrup so I used pre-made
pie sheets for the pie bakes make sure
to prick holes so pie one pops up I
between this rod shape apple tart but
wanted to make it more approachable I
also made a despite from scratch for I
try to make a pie with zero waste video
for the video I try not to make any
waste so I didn't peel the Apple it
tastes good either way
it's totally up to your preference apple
pies are official American bitter and
something I didn't also need in Japan
I like making pies and eating them
because of the seasonality since you can
make pie with any seasonal ingredients
that's something that Japanese people
are obsessed with making seasonal dishes
this needs a super easy apple pie recipe
that I made into a different style so
that it would be very pleasing it just
takes a little time
you might notice theta-not my hands
making this recipe as a tasty producer
sometimes we bring in different people
to make tasty videos with them I made
this video with my coworker Nick who is
from Louisiana I always wanted to learn
how to make good Cajun food and the best
way to do it it's learning from people
from there Louisiana andouille it's
spicy and it gives a nice smoky flavor
to the dish he told me the secret is
using andouille sausage links it's such
a simple one pot recipe but you will
taste Slayer flavors from spice the
sausage shrimp and vegetables he's no
longer working at BuzzFeed but whenever
I think of him it reminds of us cooking
together at the studio
I love how cooking bond us together so
I've been to New Orleans before I
remember how different the flavor
combination was done anything I'd ever
had before so I'm glad I had a nick
there at someone who was from that area
to teach me more about it this is
another video where it's not my hands
making the food my coworker Angie makes
the best biscuit so I asked her to make
a video with me so I can share the
recipe with space the audience angie is
our food expert foods from North
Carolina
hibiscus it's tender and flaky I can't
stop eating it whenever she makes them
there are some discussion in the comment
section that those are not biscuits
because in UK they call cookie a biscuit
American biscuits looks similar to
scones but biscuits are more moist you
can eat them with butter and jelly or
make a fried chicken sandwich so
Kentucky Fried Chicken in Japan they sub
biscuits and I used to eat them a lot
the difference between American KFC's
biscuits and Japanese camps its biscuit
it's that the Japanese biscuits has a
hole in the middle of them like a donor
I assumed this is because they can
shorten the cooking
time also just to be clear this video is
not sponsored by KFC I just didn't have
any other biscuit or American fried
chicken in Japan to compare them to I
preferred it to America Kelsie but I
know this biscuit recipe is a bust
when I was living in New York my husband
and I used to go to Key Lime pop shop in
Brooklyn they sell key lime pie on a
stick covered with chocolate it's
perfect dessert for salmon now I moved
to LA and wanted to recreate so I can
eat it all the time killing me is much
smaller than regular lime and contains
less juice and it's not accessible to
all over the world so when you squeeze
lime I always use this technique so you
cut in half and use tongs to squeeze the
juice out I learned this when I was
working in a restaurant my pastry chef
Jen showed me I should have named a as
lime pie since I didn't use key lime but
it doesn't sound as good so I used
regular line I was actually training in
French culinary at the International
Culinary Center in New York most people
probably think of me as a Japanese chef
but Japanese cooking is just what I
learned from my mom but I don't want to
be limited to just one style of cooking
my goal is not to just cook Japanese
food or cook French food I've been
living in the States almost 10 years now
it's starting to feel like here it's my
home I'm fortunate to have two places I
can call home I know I can learn so much
about other cultures cuisines through
exploring all different types of food
and if Hastie had such a diverse
audience and I'd love to hear your
background well further do you think I
should try making next oh yes
[Music]
do you want to know more okay
[Music]
[Music]